343 industries responds to halo infinite
criticism
cod season 5 is coming next week and
hype escape is coming at consoles
very soon i'm lucy and this is your save
state for thursday
july 30th my brother-in-law's birthday
please join me in wishing james a very
happy birthday
[Music]
first up 343 industries has been getting
some flack
about halo infinite's quote unquote flat
visuals
everything from an uproar of tweets to
bizarre pop shots from other brands
so the game's narrative experience
director has taken to twitter
to reply dan kosich tweeted i've been in
your shoes
i know what it's like to have
expectations built and feel let down i
want you to know your voice matters and
is heard
you're not falling on deaf ears i always
want to live up to the legacy that
bungie pioneered
i personally care a lot about honoring
that xbox marketing boss aaron greenberg
has already commented that the game is
very much a work in progress
and will only improve in visual quality
closer to launch
with ray tracing being added post
release like make the game shinier add
ray tracing
do whatever you want just please don't
touch my boy craig
all right enough mucking about a new war
zone season starts next week
i'm british and i couldn't even do that
without laughing i'm sorry
a new season in modern warfare and war
zone is due to start on august 5th and
will introduce a new battle pass
a new faction and likely a new operator
to the mix the season hasn't been
detailed just yet but rumors are abound
that this stadium may finally open up
and while i'm super excited about a new
warzone season
should we not have heard something about
a whole new card by now
seriously we're getting close to that
usual card release window
maybe it's inside the stadium i don't
know let me know your conspiracies in
the comments below
and finally ubisoft's hyperscape will
officially launch on
august 11th for pc ps4 and xbox one
this 1.0 launch will also be the kickoff
of season 1 of hype escape called the
first principle there'll be a total of
11 guns 11 hacks
and some limited time game modes but we
don't have details on all of those just
yet
we do know that there'll be a new
mid-range weapon called the dragonfly
and a new magnet hack that traps players
in place
but all progress will carry over to any
version of the game because it supports
cross-platform progression and you can
earn up to 600 bit crowns
not bitcoins during this final weekend
of the beta if you either play it
yourself
for one hour or watch eligible twitch
streams for at least
one hour eligible streams have the crown
cast extension
enabled and you have to link your uplay
account and claim at least one battle
pass point to be
eligible and don't forget the gamespot
store is donating all proceeds
until the end of august to black lives
matter and direct relief
who are helping frontline healthcare
workers battle the covid19 pandemic
head over to the link on screen or in
the description below
and for all the latest news about all
your favorite video games
keep it gamespot we'll see you next time
[Music]